- [Instructor] In this
video, we're gonna think
about what it means to subtract vectors,
especially in the context
of what we talked about
as the parallelogram rule.
So let's say we want
to start with vector a
and from that we want
to subtract vector b.
And we have vectors a and b depicted here.
What do you think this is going to be?
What do you think is going
to be the resulting vector?
Pause this video and think about that.
All right.
Now the key thing to realize
is a minus b is the same thing
as vector a plus the negative of vector b.
Now, what is the negative
of vector b look like?
Well, that's going to be a vector
that has the exact same
magnitude as vector b
but just in the opposite direction.
For example this vector right over here
would be the vector -b.
Now we just have to think about
what is vector a plus the vector -b?
Well, there's two ways
of thinking about that.
I could put the tails of both of them
at the same starting point,
might as well do the origin.
So let me draw -b over here.
So we know the vector -b looks like that.
So one way that you are probably familiar
is you have vector a and then
what you do is you take a copy
or you could think of shifting vector b
so its tail starts at
the head of vector a.
And if you did that, it
would look like this.
It would look like this.
This is also the vector -b.
And then the sum of vector a and vector -b
is going to be going
from the tail of vector a
to the head of vector -b.
So this would be the
result, right over here.
Which you could view
as the sum of a plus -b
or the difference of vectors a and b
or vector a minus vector b.
Now, if we wanna think about it
in terms of the parallelogram rule,
we could take another copy of vector a
and put it so that it's
tail's at the head of this -b
and then we would get it right over here
and we are forming the parallelogram.
And then the resulting vector
is the diagonal of the parallelogram.
And this just helps us appreciate
that we could start with -b
and then add vector a to that.
Or we could start with vector a
and then add -b to that.
But either way you get this
white vector right over here
which we can view as the
vector a minus vector b,
and we're done.